the caravan from Central America that
reach Mexico last week is now in a
pileup at Mexico's border with Guatemala
immigrants are waiting for legal entry
after Mexico decided to fast-track
humanitarian visas nearly 8,000 people
have applied in so far more than 500
visas have been issued Adriana Diaz is
in Hildago Mexico at the Guatemala
border
Adriana good morning good morning Guerra
there are essentially thousands of
migrants idled in this area because
there's a five-day waiting period for a
visa and people like the migrants behind
me who actually entered Mexico illegally
have come here backtracking to the
border so they too can get visas
desperation set in as the buses arrived
in tapa Chula 15 miles north of the
border what they're trying to do oh gosh
someone just hit someone the lines begin
forming before dawn Tuesday as word
spread that the Mexican government was
taking migrants who entered illegally to
get humanitarian visas why are you gonna
try to go to the US if Mexico's letting
you stay here to work here she doesn't
feel safe she says she can't really earn
much money here in the line we met
Salvadoran outta Guinea ax and her five
month old daughter she seized the visa
as a means to get to the US what if they
don't let you in the US what a moment
are you all burning than that she says
and they'll wait for a little bit and
try again to get into the u.s. many in
this group entered illegally in the
massive October Caravan and still want
to get to the US but some like Condor
and Penny Stewart don't plan on leaving
Mexico and done in from the 101
country okay that's not stomping
oddities that not stopping all of them
because they're not thinking Stuart
earns two dollars a day washing dishes
in Mexico but thinks that visa could
mean better pay in Honduras she was
homeless was it hard for you to decide
to leave your country
oh it sure I miss many things no up near
the US border the mayor of Tijuana says
his city won't spend one vessel on a big
group of migrants that headed north last
week now for most of the people here
they're gonna decide on their own
whether they're gonna stay in Mexico or
try to head to the US they know through
word-of-mouth and social media that the
situation at the border that tensions
are high but many are not deterred Nora
Adriana Diaz doing some incredible
reporting with your team there in Mexico
thank you so much